welcome to this video playing the champ
and he's got a good score against me so
I should probably win this would like to
lose against people who call themselves
the champ but okay I'm I tried for Kings
Indian at cem to grab this g3 Bishop and
then try to do something with with c5
okay let's go see 5pm caves so I cannot
go 95 here I can take two three I know
I'm taking if you really insist insists
on it so let's develop g5 is not looking
too great down but what can you do mmm
it's f5 right here at five and then
Knight f6 quite a shaky King position
really
hm
hmm i am not easy to play okay i'm going
to do this but it weakens enormously i'm
taking a fall under control but my king
position looks weak maybe you can just
play quincy too and yeah i just pile up
on that porn okay i have 94 TM and III
is also hanging hmm not clear at all so
my opponents yeah if they play this kind
of fishy setup like I'm play Nia they
play like b5 and just made me or
something i'm going to do that it's
probably rubbish but activity is I guess
important him okay so interesting he
wants to check them and take g5 hmm wait
is it slow and that's a very slow idea
and k i'm taking
I can actually take on Sean g5 first I
was more afraid of taking on g5 first
here I feel like I can actually allow
him to take sometimes it's not not
completely am completely decisive if it
takes on age 6 okay my idea was to play
Bishop at five here let em take em okay
I'm Eve for
yeah i mean i saw this here but a hair
tight it was was really crazy idea
Bishop g6 takes and then Bishop g4 was
my idea which is really really crazy but
maybe maybe this is so this is still
playable I've got Luke f2 coming and
this typical drunken machine gunner
style that I often load lose to only
differences if they play it against me
they would usually player instant moves
and I'm actually taking my usual time
well I'm kind of active here it doesn't
doesn't feel so simple check yeah yes I
keep it keep it there who h6 might be a
problem
new maybe I have to go Bishop g7 to kick
him kick him back
from probably it shouldn't work for me
but it is it is still very messy what is
this material wise actually am just one
point down that really true just one
pawn amazing okay really wants to take
this okay let's just be active them and
maybe you can go a 50 no II five Bishop
c2 should be okay okay still having ton
of pins going you back and have six
maybe a ticking c3r that's something
better no I don't think so
here maybe you can just go King be one
king be 194 next but okay have to
probably focus on the g-tube on yeah
it's still just one pawn and some some
ideas okay let's prove matic it quick k
well it's probably no I can take g2 now
right or is he going if five that's not
the end of the world and go Queen g7
queen of time working of two maybe it
takes d4 up g one yeah oh shoot didn't
see that one coming but now the queen is
hanging
mmm they've got queen each one that's
annoying Queen here almost made don't
they have a good move here cannot can't
believe it really I mean I can take here
nothing else okay
30 seconds 30 seconds to mars something
like that you can take the six year wow
really no my queen is protecting this
that's good okay now i can take to take
md6 now hmm not even my bishops will
help me here check I became the at least
position is okay time is not
unfortunately oh wow maybe I can still
win nearby domination check I can
actually check check white resilience oh
yeah very very unclear game no as I
stated probably it was was bad for me
but I just wanted to play actively and
see what happens yeah around here I
don't really believe in my concept but
let's see what the computer is saying
okay no it actually says that I'm better
wow it's given by the engine is here
okay the engine actually wants to check
here first and only then go Knight f6 to
prevent the capture on g5 hmm but I'm
really interested in this kind of
position engine gives b5 I actually
played that wow the computer really
likes that move that's crazy it was just
the kind of yeah let's say Gongaware do
do whatever
there should be two and our computer
wants to go before uh-huh yeah maybe I
didn't like so much to close that file
it the engine gives 91 yeah this is the
thing that I didn't consider it all
opening it up like this it really looks
good for black very active fine well
okay so I took and now exactly i took
the computer my opponent took hear the
engine gives this move after which I
cannot recapture because like Bishop g4
so I have to play something else Queen
yet on some other crazy move it's hard
to believe the engine funny enough Gibbs
give zero point to where like it like
nothing happens here but it's a
super-sharp position okay this happened
and he took Bishop f5 and amazingly the
engine likes black here or let say it's
it's it's equal this rupee eight is good
okay to a secret Wow and now Queenie
eight and black wins I'm winning here
why e 6 ie6
yeah I can't it's difficult to play now
what is why it's supposed to do I'm
threatening to take and its really kind
of overloaded here but quite sure what
happens here contigs how am i winning
here exactly i mean minus 4 is a bit cas
is a lot so what is the engine saying it
basically gives lines where I'm taking
all the pawns may be many is very
passive so that was good after all I
didn't really didn't really think about
it like that there should be three seems
to be better now and we're very tough
this Queen here ok so now the engine
just wants to get material back maybe I
should have done that yes like this and
this is really good and this also gets
material back yeah that's probably
better now we get a very messy position
gave me that wrench twins I've got
Queenie 1 i've got queen e 1 ides made
its checkmate i know i didn't see this
yeah it's checkmate oh yeah we can only
check and checkmate desperado a couple
of pieces ok then no this is probably
some kind of draw I believe my king is
active and I'm probably picking up
enough points in check but we got a
position where I could all of a sudden
demand dominate the night jam here here
black wins I think no
can take now for the wrong for the wrong
bishop hmm no I couldn't really figure
that out at this time I just had to play
play play didn't think about the wrong
color of the bishop ok good fight thanks
for watching